but when i read black lives matter and
what they were talking about which i'll
get into in a minute
i thought to myself this
philosophy in ideology is going to
damage
the lives of the young people i've spent
20 years trying to help
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantly kissing and this is a
show for you if you want honest
conversations
with fascinating people a terrific guest
today
is the ceo of an award-winning charity
and a social campaigner
nick buckley mbe welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much
it's great to have you here nick before
we get into your story which a lot of
our audience are going to find very
interesting i think
just tell everybody who are you how are
you where you are
what is the journey that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us
um that's a 50-year journey so get off a
council states
um in manchester in south manchester um
went to a failing school and didn't do
really well with me exams
and didn't go to university and did a
lot of traveling around the world i
think that really
changed me who i am then i got a job
with manchester council
and started looking in different bowls
in there started working with young
people trying to stop him getting
involved in crime and anti-social
behavior
and then when the cuts came in 2011
austere to hit i took redundancy
and used that money to invest in the
charity and i set up my own charity
to carry on working with young people on
the street to start getting involved and
making poor decisions
um and then june this year
um i did some blogging and i did a blog
on black lives matter because they'd
just come to the fore
nobody knew who they were so i went on
the website had a bit of a read and was
quite shocked about what it said
on their website so not rumors not
gossip what they put themselves on their
website
and i thought i don't know anybody knows
any of this
so i wrote a 6 700 word blog
and really talked about their website
and what was on their website
and and that hit the fan
people thought it was a racist the nazi
and when you think i've spent 20 years
working in the most
challenging neighborhoods across greater
manchester working with
thousands tens of thousands of young
people and helping supporting them
and everything just turned sour
overnight
um there was an online petition to have
me fired from the charity i set up and
founded
that got 450 signatures there was some
other email complaints went into the
board
who i appointed so a lot of them were i
was friends with
and i appointed for their skills i was
then
summarily sacked via email
and and then i mounted a fight back i
thought i'm not having this
you know if you knew me you would think
to yourself
you wouldn't take nikon if you weren't
completely sure
that what you're doing was right so i'm
out of the comeback
the online petition got 18 000
signatures compared to the 400 to get
your reinstatement
to get reinstated and got some press
attention with the mail on sunday
and then i had a solicitors firm
involved and
free of charge called keystone law um
excellent
and we're gonna need those yeah yeah um
i highly recommend that
jeffrey davis uh fantastic they looked
in my case
and within a few hours when they've made
so many mistakes here
and a week later reinstated back at the
charity i founded
and the free speech union very helpful
so this is you june we're fantastic
and it's the only organization i've ever
joined so i've never been a member of a
political party
any other union i think the only things
i've ever joined is local library and
blockbusters for your younger viewers
older viewers you know what blockbusters
is yeah um
but then i joined the free speech union
in june um and they
they were amazing they were i'd
recommend anybody if
you like talking join the free speech
union because you don't know when you
need them
and you're contributing to their coffers
and they're going to help people like me
when i did i never thought i was going
to need any help
it was my charity i set it up i
appointed the board
and i got an mbe for it
i'm not going to get cancelled how
little did i know
well that's the great thing about
nowadays is that anyone can be a nazi
yes you know we've there's everything
black white nazis white nazis jewish
nazis it's incredible
anybody you don't like is a nazi yeah
i got poor service in the shop one day
i'm kind of in statement that
well listen uh let's get into a little
bit so
first of all it just boggles the mind
because
as comedians we can understand we make a
bad joke we say something wrong
we haven't really done anything with our
lives we're sort of useless we'll just
talk
so if we get canceled it's sort of
powerful the course
you expect blah blah but you're someone
20 years you've spent working with
disadvantaged kids
helping them make a better lot for
themselves right
having yourself come from a very
difficult background
yourself right uh you work your way up
you start a charity with your own
redundancy money
you get an mbe it's your own charity
and you say something in public which is
factually based
about the blm organization
and then you just you're sacked from
your own charity
that's got some it's unimaginable isn't
it
up to the email arriving in my inbox it
was unimaginable
it's i'm still in shock now
you know the last couple of months i'm
still in shock and it's deeply affected
me as well
you know it's affected my relationships
it's affected how
i view the people on the board who i
trust as my friends you know i've known
one than 15 years
um and i don't particularly blame those
individuals i don't blame individuals
you know i put you know i put them
in a very difficult situation with that
blog even though that wasn't my
intention
that's what i did because i take
personal responsibility for this no one
else did this
i wrote the blog i posted it so i need
to take responsibility for it
and i still look at those individuals
and they were
still wonderful individuals the day
before they sent that email
so therefore they're still wonderful
individuals now they just weren't up for
a fight
and that's the only difference so i
don't want to fall into the trap that
other people do you know
they're nasty they're evil they're
left-wing
commies they were just nice people just
weren't up for a fight
yeah and nick the question i'm really
interested in asking is this what were
your criticisms of blm
of the blm organization i'll make that
over what in particular did you disagree
with
so i think first thing i need to tell
you why i wrote it because i didn't like
this because
i'd spare 10 minutes and i'm always
sticking my nose into a people's
business and now you know i've never
commented anything around
extinction rebellion who i don't support
or extinction rebellion
doesn't fall under the rim of my charity
of what we're trying to do what we're
trying to achieve so
i wouldn't comment on that and become an
expert
but when i read black lives matter and
what they were talking about which i'll
get into in a minute
i thought to myself this
philosophy and ideology is going to
damage
the lives of the young people i've spent
20 years trying to help
it's hard enough being brought up in the
inner city it's hard not being brought
up in poverty
without having a national movement an
intellectual movement telling you
that you're a victim that the police
about hunting you down every night
that the reason why you fail is because
you're black you're bound because you're
muslim because you're this because
you're a woman
and i know a lot of young people and
it's quite tempting and i i was
i was one of those that's why i've only
been doing this for 20 years and i'm 52.
so what they're doing
for 30 years i wasted my life that's
what i did
so i know how easy it is to get
distracted
so if we're giving young people
a solid gold reason not to try in life
because
what's the point i'm black what's the
point i've been told by all these
politicians that
you know i'm a victim then i'm there
going
no you're bloody not and don't listen to
them because that's a self-fulfilling
prophecy
if you think you're going to fail in
life i guarantee you're going to fail in
life
and success is what you make it success
isn't you're going to be an
international footballer
the odds are you're not going to get
that but you can judge what success is
and success might might be stacking
shelves aside
and having a legal job that pays the
rent and you have a wife and kids
that's success but also if you want to
be a doctor
of a nurse or it doesn't matter
sort out yourself what success is and
then aim for that
because we're not going to be brain
surgeons or or footballers so
so you deem what success is and when i
read what they vote on their website
about dismantling
yeah dismantling the nuclear family
that's the biggest problem we've got in
the cities
no bloody fathers and they want to
dismantle
the nuclear family and break it down
and then you read them on to defund the
police which means abolish the police
i don't know anybody who wants to
abolish the police he tends to have
police where we have crime
and the poorest people in the poorest
neighborhoods are the biggest victims of
crime
not the leafy suburbs it's the people
living in in the cities
and all of them and someone who speaks a
lot of them they all want more police
not less police and we've seen what
happened in america when
all of a sudden the police disappear you
know gunfire goes through the roof
violence goes through the roof look at
new york city at the moment i think
homicides have increased 2 300
something like that over the last few
months and we're telling
the poorest people and the people who
need the most and the most protection
that we're going to abolish the police
for you mate and i'm reading all this on
their website
and i'm thinking do i have enough cases
but i've had someone thought they're not
not cases the marxist
this is the way to tear down our society
and our culture and our country
especially when they say we want to
overthrow capitalism
but what does that mean well there's
only one option from capitalism
and it's socialism which means communism
and we tried communism maybe a dozen
times last century it a really good goal
yeah yeah yeah your ancestors gave it a
really good goal yeah
and did it work anyway no all it left
left was tens of millions of bodies
and capitalism isn't perfect you know
capitalism
it's you know what the church will say
it's it's the work
it's the the worst best system we've
ever
come across at the moment that we've
developed at the moment it's not perfect
you know and capitalism that's a
tendency of leave you know the poor
and the vulnerable stacking up at the
bottom and that's
people we need to help so we need a
compassionate capitalism we don't need
to tear all this down
and try again a failing system that
never works
anywhere else i read this and i thought
this is going to destroy everything i've
spent two decades trying to change
across greater manchester and that's why
i wrote the blog i thought people need
to know about this
not because of me my big mouth because
it's going directly against
what the charity was set up to do to
help the exact people
this is gonna damage and that's why i
want the blog
so let's talk about that you talk about
i can't remember the exact phrase i
don't think it's about dismantling the
nuclear family but something about
disrupting the nuclear family
requirement or some [ __ ]
but they still want to live in massive
communes or whatever it is
um you talk about the inner city let's
start with
with the the rise of the single parent
household
what sort of impact on the young people
that you work with
would having more single parenthood
have for those people so
if we go to my experience my personal
experience
single-payer household uh mom did a
fantastic job
and we had no money but i knew i was
loved how did we know a nice happy
family
growing up and all my friends had that
so we know
we're looking at 30 40 years ago
and if you've asked me then do i miss
having a father i don't remember my
father
i think we left when i was two and the
answer would be no i've not missed it at
all
you know there's nothing i could have
got extra out of it
but then the first time i realized i had
missed out
i was 23 years old sat with my friends
in the bay garden in manchester one
summer's day
having a drink and everyone's talking
about shaving and someone just bought
the new gillette
shaver i bought this i bought that i'm
all talking about shaving
and they all said they shaved the way
the dad taught to shave
and when it came to me they said how do
you shape me i went i've got electric
razor
oh why'd you use that to razor and i
said
well i looked in some drawers once in
the house when i was 14 and found an old
electric razor and i started shaving
with that and i've shared with it ever
since
and it was that that conversation i
realized oh
i have missed having a five in my life
not dramatically it wasn't you know a
life changing thing
and then i started thinking if
if i missed out on that what else have i
missed out on
to help me mold me into being a man to
having
um you know inspiration to trying to
achieve something and
the answer is i don't know because you
don't know what you've missed when you
don't know it was there
so taking that forward now to young
people in the inner cities
when i meet young people there's i've
got two ways
of knowing if they're vulnerable to
making really poor choices in life
the first one is the failing education
so if i'm talking to young people and
they're saying they hate school
they're never in school they've been
kicked out of school
it's a huge warning scientist because i
know they're vulnerable after being
pulled into
criminality making negative choices
and the other warning sign is i have no
father at home
and if you've got both of them then you
know you're extremely vulnerable to
making poor choices
we really underestimate as a society
and we don't even we don't we're not
allowed to talk about this because if
you talk about this
it's as if we're attacking single moms
and i'm not attacking single moms do an
amazing job
under so much pressure and stress what
i'm saying is
they'd be under less pressure than
stress and have an easier life
if we had the fat over there and
who i'm blaming are the fathers i'm not
blaming the single moms i'm saying to
men
and boys how dare you knock somebody up
and it's your child and you take no
responsibility
ever for your child then how dare you do
that
this is your flesh and blood growing
inside
you know this woman who's then going to
give birth it's going to be your child
who's then going to have other children
and you don't want to be part of their
life and you don't want to
provide for that child and be a man
and take responsibility how dare you not
want to do that
and you're going to leave it to the
state to bring up your child
i'll tell you what the state will do a
bloody poor job
of bringing up your child a poor job
you need to get some responsibility and
you need to raise your own children
that's what you need to do and that's
aimed at the men
not at single mums who do a good job
under hard circumstances
i want them to have more help and
support and it's the men
as a society we need to be going after
and saying
just like we used to do with drink
driving when i was
a kid in the 70s i always went to my
uncle's car he was drunk and we drive us
home
and we all knew he was drunk and it was
acceptable now
you'd phone the police if you knew
someone was driving in someone's kid's
home you'd phone the police
and that's what we need to do with men
who are not taking responsibility
for their children children need a
father and a mother
in less exceptional circumstances if
your dad's a violent murdering pedophile
do you know what you'll do better than
life without having a relationship with
him
so that's a caveat but on the whole
children need both bands so that blm
recommendation
not constructive not helpful that's
disastrous disastrous
okay so let's go to the next one which
is
abolish the police defund the police now
they say defund means something else
there's a lot of [ __ ] but then
there's a new york art
new york times article comes out where
they go no no we mean abolish the police
so let's take them at the word
abolish the police what would be the
impact
in the inner city like manchester
of removing the police officers who are
there
yeah and replacing them with
quote-unquote social workers what would
be the impact of that well first of all
i spent nearly a decade
as a community safety manager for
manchester council
and every residence meeting i went to
every victim of crime i spoke to
in the inner cities lots of them be me
would all say i want more police on my
street
where would the police i want more
police
not one person ever said to me do you
know what nick
i'm sick of saying i'm sick of saying
police around here not one person's
ever said for me in the decade i worked
in the crank field at manchester council
everybody wants more police it makes you
feel safer
if we reduce the amount of police and we
have done the prospect manchester i
think we've lost
over 2 000 police officers in the last
decade because of stability
the met has lost a hell of a lot more
than that
if you take police out of those
neighborhoods you're basically
handing that over to organized crime and
you hand that over
to dysfunctional young people who commit
low-level crime and anti-social behavior
and will run amok i remember growing up
on a council estate
50 years ago where anti-socialist
behavior and low-level trying
was not only everyday it was
culturally acceptable i remember some
kid running
across my street with half a leg a lamp
half a
half a lamb because someone was
delivering meat to local butchers
and as he popped in this lad jumped to
the back and picked up
half half a sheep and went on with it
and everybody knew who'd done it
no one said anything it was all
acceptable we've got away from that now
because it looks like a victim this
crime but there's no victim this crimes
in society
and if we remove police from these areas
or just reduce them
anti-such behavior go through the roof
low-level crime will go through the roof
and then we'll have organized crime
taking over
and what we'll have then is then we'll
have vigilantes you know
i've organized crime walking around
going i'll sort that burglar out for you
and they might not even be the person
who burgled your house but they'll get a
good idea they were stabbing
because we thought it was him and that's
not how we want to run our society
with lawlessness and vigilances
and gangs running our neighborhoods we
need more police not less police
there's an argument for better policing
absolutely
and you know i've trained police
officers in community engagement
you know i did that for several years
every now and again working with great
manchester police
police need you know to improve their
training i'm sick of police you see on
tv those tv shows drive me mental
if i hear one more police officer
speaking to a member public and calling
mate
all right mate what you're doing tonight
all right love you know calm down don't
be drinking
excuse me you call him sir and you call
her madam
you don't call him mate and love if
someone from british gas turns up my
my house i wanted to call me sir i'm
paying for service here
i'm not your mate be professional
and so we can improve the police and
they need to no we need to raise their
game
on the whole they're fantastic i'm a big
supporter of the police
but they can be improved so we can
improve and help train the police better
but reducing them and getting rid of
them
is absolutely true i can
only say it's a craziest idea i think
i've ever heard i like that because
halfway through it sounded like you were
giving him a bollocking
which i deserve to be yeah which you do
deserve which i very much enjoy now we
i think pretty much everybody who looks
at these ideas
knows that they're crazy knows that they
are fundamentally unworkable
so why have we got into this position
where they have become
impossible to criticize do you remember
the documentary
that bbc did on black lives matter when
they went into the background of who
they are and how they set up
we didn't see it no i don't did you see
it i've done it no no does it exist
that's why no one knows what black lives
matter stands for because not one
reputable mainstream media organization
has looked as done a half hour
documentary into interview live matter
that's why nobody knows about it as
simple as that
i speak to my friends my all my friends
up to me educating them
think black lives matter is just a
movement that came out of racism in the
uk and i say
it's an organization they have a website
they've collected millions of pounds
have they i didn't know that well these
are some of their views
i never knew that well how would they
unless they've got the time and
inclination to do some research
which most people haven't then
the mainstream media completely letters
down
where is the documentary about who black
lives matter
i'm not saying attack him or a factual
bbc
panorama horizon
news night type of documentary
this is black lives matter started six
years ago in america
of a shooting of some
black young person who said he had his
hands up it turns out he didn't have his
hands up
all the way through now and let's have a
proper factual documentary but no one's
made it
and the mainstream media don't want to
make it so we're kept in ignorance
they're scared i mean this is why you
say people aren't educated but
there are also people and i can tell you
this from personal experience
in the media higher up in different
nationalists of different
organizations you talk to them you sit
them down and you go
you know here's the fact about this this
is what they propose this is
and they go um and then they don't say
anything
because they know the punishment as you
now know the punishment
which is if you make these perfectly
legitimate observations
i mean you say they say so themselves
they found one of the co-founders of blm
said in 2015
that they're trained marxist yeah i saw
the video you're talking about right
so it's not a secret it's not a secret
there's no secret about it but a lot of
people
simply don't want to say that that's
what's happening and therefore they'll
pretend they don't know
it's a bit like five christmas on the
easter bunny
we know it's made up we know it's crazy
but we're not going to go around saying
it's all made up in phase because it
might upset
the people you still believe in it we
call them children
so we don't want to upset them and if
you've got the big directors of those
big organizations you know the truth
they're not stupid they've already
looked into this
but you're right they're seeing what's
happened to people like me
and other people and they're thinking
i don't want to lose my quality million
pound year job and my
amazing pension for saying something
that i know people don't want to hear
this is my job and nick did you have any
idea
of the hot water hot water you were
going to get into
by writing this blog or did you think it
was a legitimate criticism
and you were just going to go about your
day
i thought there would be
some criticism because social media
you know i could i could i could
potentially be my date of birth
somebody there would be some criticism
yeah
um did i think it'd be anything like
what happened
no because you know would i have posted
it
if i had if i'd known
i really don't know i'd like to think i
would i'd like to think
yes i would but i'd be that's far too
easy to answer
would i have posted it knowing that the
turmoil
and you know the the hurt and you know
just what i've been through what i have
done it i've
i really couldn't answer that but no i
didn't expect it to go
bat [ __ ] crazy like it did but do you
regret posting no
why not um because i believe i was right
and i believe i've been proven right and
i believe
if i had posted that blog today it made
no waves
i agree i was ahead of the curve yeah
and if you're trying to be a leader
in any field you're in and if you're
trying to improve the lives of people
you care about
then you need to do what's right not
what's convenient
and it was right at that moment in time
for me to try to educate
whoever was following me on social media
about what i
discovered i didn't know i discovered
and when people need to know about this
so i then try to educate and inform
other people
so i don't regret doing it at all and
so you say that you don't regret doing
it and you look at the government's
handling of blm
i personally think it was weak what
handling exactly
so what what are your criticisms of the
government do you think they handle well
that's the biggest that's the biggest
problem we've got
um i can only say i've never been so
disappointed in the government than with
one we've got at the moment i voted for
this government
and not because of policies not because
i called it because let's be honest
we're all making covered up as we go
along because no one knows what they're
doing
every country is doing the best what
they think is right because when they've
had this before so i'm not even blaming
them for that all of us know we have
even now where's the leadership when
they're pulling down statues
and graffiti you know the churchill
statue
and attacking the police and
i can't i can't i can't name one
politician who stood up
and went no no
no no not in this country not today
and not while i've got my seat in
parliament if you don't like what i'm
saying
vote me out because i'm going to say
what i believe
vote me out if you don't if you disagree
with me but i'm having none of this
the whole country was begging for
someone to
to stand boris johnson was on death's
door so
he still could have done more regardless
you know we had a world war ii pilot
with no legs flying spitfires
so just because you know you're ill or
you've lost it doesn't mean sure can't
do anything he still should have done
more
i'm extremely angry and disappointed
without government
about how they did nothing how they made
everybody else feel
i better say nothing because even the
government's afraid
of the mob and if they ever faded them
up
i work in tescos i work in a factory
i don't say anything and i'd better put
that blm pokemon window
i better start making those fist salutes
i better start putting a black square on
instagram
because if the government's afraid then
i need to be terrified
and they really dropped the ball
absolutely dropped the ball
i know an actor who was
forced by her agent to put a black
square on
on their instagram because
if you don't you're going to lose work
yes so that terror you're talking about
and you're right i think it rose all the
way to the top all the way to the top
but coming back to you and your
situation
it sounds to me like the people who
sacked you from your own charity
they didn't do it because they were sort
of ardent blm marchers who'd been
out there protesting they did it for
likely the same reasons
that people were doing everything else
which is this is scary
we're going to get punished this looks
bad
and they just didn't want to make the
stand that you did
yes it was a sort of soft cowardice you
might say
possibly i mean i'm putting it quite
strange in strong terms i don't i'm not
attacking the people i'm just saying
they were unwilling to make a stand
let's say um
was that it that was was that the extent
you think of it
yeah they just didn't want to deal with
the trouble yeah but why
fire you then why not just like say they
don't support you
why would they sack you from your own
charity again
a lot of this comes down to kovid months
and months being locked away
all of us hyper sensitive all of us
spending far too much time on social
media we've got nothing else to do
and if there's been normal times i think
the email would have been
nick we all need a face to face here
it's kovid
so there was no face to face um
they were probably looking at the
chavity and thinking we've got lots of
corporate supporters and they're
probably looking
some of these carpet supporters are
actively supporting blm
they're not happy and my answer would
have been i don't care
i set this charity up they can pull
their money it's not a lot of money
anyway
but i'm not sacrificing the futures
of the young people on the streets just
so we can get a couple of extra grand
off this corporate because i'll take a
pay cut
you know we can save the money somewhere
else i'm not
selling my soul and what i believe just
for the next couple of grand
because we're damaging young people that
the charity was set up to help
and that's what i always came back to
and that's all the decisions i've made
for the charity was is this decision the
right thing for those kids on the
streets
because if it is well we make that
decision is this this the best decision
for me to get a pay rise
well i shouldn't be answering that
question the question always should be
about young people
trying to help and they probably looked
to
many things i'm guessing i wasn't in
their mind i didn't even sit down have a
conversation with them
and they they panicked they saw some
complaints coming
they saw the 450 signatures which at the
time
seemed a lot of people 450 people all
want nick
sacked these people are saying he's a
nazi he's a racist
some of these people are obviously black
look at the faces on twitter
they must know what they're talking
about so we've got to letting it go
and how did it work did you have any
inkling that you were going to get fired
or did you simply walk into an office
and then it get delivered to you there
emails it was all over email so you got
psyched from your entirety by email
yes immediate immediate i mean the
effect
on and did you have any idea that this
was going to happen
no so effectively you got an email out
of the blue firing you from your own
charity
that you set up the effect on you must
have been devastating
the first week it's hard to admit i was
a beaten man the first week
because i walked out i went
you idiot you and your
big mouth when will you ever learn
to keep your mouth shut that's all i was
saying to myself
people are laughing at you now those 450
people are definitely laughing at you
people you've worked with other agents
and other charities they're all laughing
at you
who does he think he is he was always
spouting off in meetings he was always
saying we could do better he was always
saying
our plans were wrong and look at him now
yeah well glad that that's what i was
thinking
uh first week i was a beaten man
absolutely i look back now and i think
oh
i couldn't have got any lower and then
the second week
i got a phone call for friends who said
what are you doing nick i said what do
you mean
you've not replied to anybody not one he
met not not one anything on social media
you've not challenged anybody you know
they're calling you nazi here
you're not even come back even with an
insult to them
you just accept it all and as if you're
guilty
and we all know you're not guilty why
why are you lying down
because i was beaten so i went to bed
that night and that was i didn't sleep
um that's all that was going on in my
head
was was that conversation i woke up next
tomorrow and i thought right
the least i can do now is fight back and
clear my name
probably won't get my job back but
unless i clear my name
my next step in my life is going to be a
lot harder because it'll be do i mean
the nazi and i thought well that can't
be my minute rest of my life
so i thought at least i need to fight
back and then
confidence happen in life you know i've
always had a good look
i always argue is it good luck or was
the fact that i was willing to take an
opportunity that evolved so i don't
think it was luck
anyway that morning knocking the door
open my front door
hi i'm a reporter from the mail on
sunday can i have a chat and i went
just a man let me get the kettle on
so uh it wasn't that flipping i went
coming i need to properly think about
this before
i do an interview and i wasn't that
flippant and so we had a good chat
gave an interview and i thought about
that that's the beginning of the fight
back let's get some national press on
this
um and then one of the former trustees
of the charity phoned up and said i
can't believe what's happened
and he said do you mind if i set up a
alternative petition
to get you being stated because i don't
want to do it by asking you in case it
makes things worse
i went no do it so he set that up um
and then i went on the offensive um as
much press i could do
um on top radio quite a bit and
lots of stuff on twitter and facebook
that was generating lots of complaints
then to the charity board
to say why did you sack this man so all
of a sudden
i flipped the pressure pressure wasn't
on me anymore now
pressure went back onto the board of the
charity why have you done this
what was their formal reason for
snacking you formal reason was
bringing the three points never
mentioned
the blog so three points was something
like bringing the charity distributes
spouting political ideology
um and breaching charity commission died
it's interesting do you think that if
you'd made a statement in
support of black lives matter do you
think that would have been regarded as
spouting political opinions
no because almost every charity before
that
was all supporting black lives matter
that's interesting because i would
imagine that's sort of a political
position as well isn't it if it's a
political position to criticize then
it's a political position to endorse
it turns out when you read the charity
commission guidance
none of that comes under their
definition of political
it's about supporting british
political parties right around laws or
getting him elected
and this was the american organization
so it didn't even come under that
yeah and so this happened so you started
your fight back at this point did you
want to return to the charity
or did you just want to highlight what
actually happened to you and the
injustice behind it
to begin with i was trying to claim a
name that's how i thought this is
you know let you do in life when you've
got plans you have a series of
of goals and my first goal was i need to
claim a name i can't be known as
nick remember the charity guy the nazis
so i wanted to claim my name on that
the best thing that someone called me
was a compassionate nazi i got a tweet
saying
i'll take on board your two decades of
working in these tough neighborhoods
supporting kids and you're obviously
very compassionate
but you're still a nazi you are a
compassionate nazi
and i thought about changing my twitter
handle and i thought no
i don't i don't want to go for the rest
of my life with the word nazi
in my twitter and stuff like that but i
thought it was quite funny so i want to
claim a name first of all
and when i could see that was happening
and i was getting i mean i literally got
maybe a thousand personal messages on
facebook on twitter
from all over the uk from france from
australia from america
saying we've seen it in the press we've
got our full support anything we can do
i had the one another um english
businessman
um offered to pay my wages
in case i was really struggling and i
was getting so much support and
that changed my perspective then i
thought
if i had any doubts that what i'd done
was right and i did have doubts on what
i've done was right because when all of
a sudden you face that
it's like and i'm a reflective person so
i'm thinking
maybe i am wrong maybe i did cross the
line here
why would all these people be against me
and no one's for me that was another
strange thing
no one in that first couple of weeks no
one came to my defense
no one i had a couple of emails and
phone calls send i'd like to
but after i see what's happened to you
nick i didn't do anything public but
just let me know that i am on your side
just not publicly um and then when all
that happened i thought oh i might be
able to get the charity back here
um so it was a second to be thought it
wasn't my initial thought and then when
i got solicitors keystone law
involved and they looked at everything
they went this looks like an open and
shut case to us mate
they're saying we really think you'll be
back in the seat this time next week
oh really and they respond wow and what
would you say to people
who invariably say cancel culture it's a
myth it doesn't exist
you know where you know you're free to
say whatever you want
um we need to define what cancer culture
is
because it's become this term for
everything now
so if i are sick of your pulse on
twitter
and i block you that's not cancer
culture that's me just sick of your
tweets
but people are going oh he's blocked me
you're talking about council culture but
yet you block me and that's not council
culture and it's not council culture if
it's
you know you're an actor and also
i don't like your political views and
it's not council culture to say do you
know what
i used to be a fan of yours but i'm not
now that's not council culture council
culture is when you say
i don't like what you're saying or what
you think and i want to try to destroy
your life
i'm going to go after if you work for
someone i'm going after them so they
know
i'm going to go after you put on twitter
that your sister works for
virgin trains well i'm going to go after
your sister on virgin trains now because
i want to die destroy you if you're an
actor
you know i want to set a petition on
that we all boycott the film you had a
full second role in
and i want to make sure that all of the
diabetes producers know
if you're in anything that a lot of
trouble comes with that
that's council culture where you try to
describe someone's life
not when you say i don't i don't hear
you mate so therefore
i'm to do something so i don't hear you
that's perfectly acceptable
that's not cancelled culture it's when
you want to destroy someone and
having experienced it yourself do you
think it's more prevalent
than we actually like to think in the uk
um i'm about to say yes because i'm more
attuned to it now and i see it more
i probably didn't see it as much before
but youtube gents who do this podcast
and speak to lots of people
you're probably better positioned to to
know it looks like it's happening more
especially since black lives matter
because we've suddenly got this
new justice warrior type now who was
involved
a few months ago and it's easier to do
it now
and it's easy to do it because every one
of those individuals
completely believes that they're 100
right
and that they're on god's side that they
were martin luther king side
that if gandhi and mandela are here
today
they're on their side and they 100
believe that
and what we believe people like us is
i think i'm right
i'm not saying i'm 100 i think i might
based on what i've read and what i've
seen and what i felt
and i'm quite happy listening to
somebody else in case they can change my
mind
or in case they know something i don't
know
so it's hard to have a fair fight when
we think we're right
and they know they know their rights
and it's an unfair fight i think a lot
of it is what we talked about earlier
and
you sort of cringed a little bit when i
suggested the uh
the people who sacked you are cowards
but i think
not speaking about them personally but
more broadly i think that's a big
part of it because in your case
450 people signing a petition you could
get 450 people to sign a petition about
the color of trains right that anything
but it seems like a lot and then at that
point people have to have some backbone
to say
actually we don't care that 450 people
who we don't know
who have no identity verification we
don't even know if there's one person
who created 450 accounts
could be right it takes some backbone
to stand up against it and i think part
of the reason that
there is cancellation happening is that
people just afraid
good people good people are just afraid
so
let's talk about the process further
down the line which is you get the
lawyers involved
they tell you it's an open shot case
what happens from there
so the board of trustees uh this list
supports them
um outlining their mistakes and where
they were wrong and
[Music]
that i was going to sue them for unfair
dismissal
so i breached a contract um
upon behaving that then seeing the
evidence and obviously then then
getting legal advice themselves which
she probably should have done before
um they realized the mistake
um and decided to resign
so they appointed another board who i
approved
a new board was appointed and then they
reinstated me
wow and so you you're back where you
should rightfully be at the helm of your
charity
and what advice would you give to people
about speaking out
about criticizing we all need to speak
out and when
you were just saying then about
cowardice we're all guilty of that
we're all guilty none of us do enough
even now
i see things i think should i comment i
shouldn't have comment
and i don't comment anything even though
partly wants to comment on that because
i believe in something
and i like to think at the moment i'm
probably still a little bit
not vulnerable i'm probably still a
little bit well it's a bit damaged and
it's
could i mentally cope with a double
outbreak and it's like
you know what i don't want to give that
a go so maybe in a couple of months time
when i'm a bit stronger and a bit more
solid
then i do and hence why i'm on your show
this is the real reason why i'm here
because i want to speak out i want
to be a voice for everybody else
i want to show people and tell people
this can be beaten
and it could be beaten fairly easy
nobody puts up when i did my
right fought back no one no one fought
back against me they didn't rise back up
just like school bullies when it's 10 of
us
we're gonna pick on you something awful
all of a sudden you're fighting back
oh someone easy around the corner to
bully let's go up and go with them
because
you're just caught in too many problems
for me now as a bully i'm
gonna pick someone else nobody when i
start the fight back
no one there was no negative comments on
social media
no one's emailed me to complain that i'm
back in post
no one's emailed the board saying why
did you take that nazi back
they shut up once that mail on sunday
article here
every single one of them shut up because
all of a sudden there's thousands of
people online
in support of me and they all went
we're not taking on a crowd it's too
dangerous we know it's like
when you're a crowd and what you can do
to people that's a bigger crowd we're
not taking them on
so we all need to stand up what we don't
need is matters i don't want people
losing their jobs
standing up over something that was
trivial or
something you couldn't change and you
know we don't need more martyrs out
there
who are self-sacrificing themselves but
everyone can do a bit
and if everyone just doesn't know we're
the silent majority
the vast 90 of the country agree with us
if everyone interested a tiny bit and
you add all that up
that's like a tidal wave of support and
we can
crush the descent that we get and these
lunatics we can crush them
in a nice way and that's what we need to
do
everybody needs to do their bit so if
you read something on twitter and you
think yeah i can retweet that
retweet it or like it if you want to
comment on something
comment on something but be sensible
what we don't need
is our version of those nut cases out
there because all you do then
is you'll you give them another reason
to to double down and say
look at that some of them are basis we
don't need
to play their game the way they go we
need to beat them
first of all with emotion not facts
they don't hear facts you can give them
all the facts you want
they're running on emotion so we need we
need to tackle them with emotion
and we need to say this is what we're
trying to achieve
we want to achieve the same things as
you a favorite society
no racism lots of opportunity for
everybody
no homeless people no we want the same
things as you
of course we do but these ways of
getting there
with some of your ideas and some of our
ideas we can get there
as opposed to saying we're just going to
attack them for attacking them saying
we need to have a better strategy of how
we're going to do this
i'm not formulating one at the moment so
i'm having about some articles or maybe
a book or something about
how we're doing this and it's not about
attacking them yeah because the vast
majority of decent people
we need to pull them onto our side
what we don't need to do is to be
knocking them off one at a time
and beating them let's pull them all on
our side and then you've got a couple of
cent
of marxist lunatics that we can all turn
around
and then just mock so it's about being a
compassionate nazi
when you run for office that can be a
slogan mate um
no i agree with you and i i think the
point you're making is very important
which is
i i've been thinking about this for the
last few months which is
if this is a war which is it's kind of
been set up
it can't be a war that's my point it
can't be it could all be doing
it's a civil war yeah yeah that's what
we all lose in a civil war
this has to be i hate the word war i
hate i hate the term
um culture war yeah and because what
we're doing is
subconsciously we're setting each of
weapon camps yeah and you know
american i was getting close to a civil
a physical civil war got people killing
each other now
this needs to be a war of ideas it needs
it needs to be a war of emotion what it
really needs
to be is a conversation and that's what
you're saying is you have to be sensible
so that other people don't get put off
so you can actually have a conversation
i don't think we're there yet for
conversation
that's why that's why i'm saying to
people we need
we need to tackle them with positive
emotion because they're running on
emotion
yeah then they're not willing to listen
to facts or have a conversation
or to give you the benefit of doubt that
you used to and not racist
so if they can't give you the i i give
everyone a benefit of doubt
that they're not a racist unless they
prove me wrong
i give everyone a benefit of doubt that
they're a decent person
unless they prove me wrong and that's
how we should treat everybody in society
but everybody got an emotion
so we need i'm not sure how we do it yet
but
having conversations and
them facts we can do that like house
come on
and would you change anything about your
experience and what you went through
i would the blog would have been bought
better
i didn't like how much scrutiny it was
going to get so even there's nothing in
there
that i regret writing as you know you
can word things slightly differently
i could have made points slightly better
so
i don't regret writing it nothing that
i'm ashamed of either
but i could have voted a little bit more
academically
a little bit more as if i was a english
lit
major or something i could have made it
a bit better but i didn't because
i'm just a kid off the council estate
and i just had to spare half an hour
but a website thought oh my on this
indeed so that could have been better to
change that
um no i'm not one for regrets
yeah i'm not one to you know cuddle with
the sugar
no duns don't i need to learn from what
i did
because you're a fool if you don't learn
from things that go wrong in your life
so i need to learn from that
but i don't regret any of it it's taking
me to a place
where i am now and it's given me
it's given me a new challenge in life so
i'm still going to work for the charity
but i'm looking at going part-time
because i want to start dedicating some
of my time do a lot more writing on
social issues i want to get involved in
policy
i want to drive some of the agendas and
be an influencer
as opposed to helping a few thousand
kids a year which is great and amazing
but if i can influence policy and i can
help bring down something like black
lives matter the organization
not the phrase then i can have a bigger
impact and do more good
well let's talk about that because i
think we if we put a bow
on your story there's a happy ending
yeah and that's a good thing
and congratulations to you on that uh
and to all the people who supported you
yeah big thanks to the people who
supported me and you know keystone law
the uh once the students union then but
uh the free
speech union were amazing and everybody
everybody messaged me
really helped me get through this
because i was at a really low place and
having
having reading weeks i've been called a
nazi to then get messages get
saying you know look at the great things
you've done and look at this and look at
that
and look at this old article that i
heard about four years ago where
you saved a girl from being sexually
abused and you know they sent me the
article i thought
i have done some good work yeah and you
know you start doubting yourself so they
really helped me
yeah so let's talk about the future then
because i think one of the
most important conversations that we
started sort of at the beginning was
it was about what made you criticize the
organization of blm
which is you thought their prescriptions
for what should happen in inner cities
were fundamentally mistaken yes they're
fundamentally damaging
to people who live in those communities
and particularly the
vulnerable young people with whom you
work so
what are the things that people don't
understand about
in the city young people knife crime gun
gun crime gangs all of this sort of
stuff that you would have
experienced dealing with what do people
need to know we have politicians who
watch the show we have journalists who
watch the show
what do they need to understand that
they do not understand at the moment
that's a billion dollar question that
one i think that we could do a 10
10 episode yeah savings on that um
it's just really complicated so some of
some of the simple things
one is education i've just spoke um an
article for the critic magazine
on what i think we need to look at in
our education system
because one size fits all doesn't work
for everybody
so according to government stats eight
to two percent of young people
in england who attend school achieve the
five gcses which is the government
minimum standard that means 18
don't it's the 18
who are being failed at school and we
need to look at how do we educate them
and i give a couple of examples of a
girl i knew who was a lovely girl
wasn't very bright but but was just a
lovely person
and you know could achieve in life
because of her innate
ability of making people go i like her
and we've all met those people
and she has to deal with no
qualifications hardly attending the
classes
because she just wasn't academic
and if we had a different school around
the corner
that wasn't a dumping balance for
academically challenged kids
or behavioral challenged kids this isn't
you know a pupil referral unit
this is the school your parent chooses
for you
as opposed to you get sent because it's
all about choice i want parents and kids
to have choice
but could have other schools where young
people who are not academically gifted
or it might be
but just don't as sick as sitting in
lessons and they have a choice
they go to these schools where it's more
practical so still do english maths
things like that
but then you know there could be you
know there could be classes where they
you know
people could do coding if that's what
they want to leave school and do
and this girl i give an example where
she could have been trained as a
chambermaid
and was never going to do an academic
job but she could have understood you
know
working turn up on time customer service
and invoicing simple hotel computer
systems
children left school and there's
hundreds of hotels in our state center
should do a job like that
but i bumped into her when she was 17
now
morbidly obese never had a job and he's
now unemployable
and we've taken her spark away she
smiled all the time when i knew her when
i met him when she was 17
in the city center just walking past we
stopped for the chat didn't smile once
we'd whatever was in it our education
system
rips out of it and that's only a small
percentage of young people
but that doesn't mean we let them fail
just because the vast majority doing
well at school
and those young people are also the
young people then who then get dragged
into crime they get grooms
can they get kicked out of school come
to behavior or they stop attending
school because
you imagine you go to school for 11
years you want to go to school every day
and you're not academically gifted
and every day you sit in a class and
every day they make you feel
more and more stupid and you see other
people getting it
and you can't get it and you start
getting angry
and you start thinking i'm not coming
anymore now you start getting
disenfranchised you start thinking
society's against you
and you wonder why by the time you've
left at 15 16
you're an angry young man you wonder why
we just talked to you for 11 years
made you feel stupid inadequate and
nobody
all those years but the best intentions
they don't do it on purpose i get that
and then you wonder why the hang on the
streets hanging out and you wonder why i
drug deal going
come here mate i want to win 10 quid do
you want to do this this this
it's like i'm finally being treated like
an equal they're not
but they think i'm being treated like an
equal i could be him
i could be the godfather i could have
this big house
and the odds are no you're gonna get
stabbed in a couple years timing up in
jail
but they buy into the dream because i've
education let them down
that's something we can do and you know
the way we're kicking kids out of school
into the arms of criminal gangs is
tremendous in all the inner cities
and then we've got an issue with our
culture
and if you look at some of the biggest
hits for tv shows over the last couple
of years
peaky blinders what's that organized
crime
breaking bad what's that organized crime
drug dealing
we're selling young people the dream of
it's a career
subconsciously look at the music we
listen to
that music and stuff like that all
negative messages
all the time you know gangs and drugs
and
killing and respect
and then we've also got some in this
city culture and family about
not appreciating and looking at the
value of education
and we've got lots of immigrant families
coming
big on education you speak to you know a
british chinese kid of indian kid
or a nigerian kid their kids are going
to do
our state comprehensive in a poor area
they're the kids who excel their parents
are saying
what we've done then look at your report
card go get the belt
two b's go get the belt and that's
they're doing really well to be clear
we're not advocating
but i know what you mean and they value
education
yeah yeah and i remember once 20 years
ago sat
in you're not that compassionate if
you've got development you've got you've
got to stick to your label compassionate
nazi
we all need discipline sure and i don't
condone
you know go back but i know some
families do that um
i remember saturn sitting in a house and
talking to a mum once about her daughter
who was causing problems and local
chippy bit of racial abuse and local
chippy
and i visited the house sat down and
said no this can't go on
and these are consequences for your
daughter if this goes on
um and i'm sat in this house nicely
decorated the biggest tv i've ever seen
this was like 15 20 years ago i don't
have a flat screen tv at the time and
she had this
size of a wall flat screen tv was on
benefits
didn't work and i'm trying to say she
needs to go to school that's the problem
i never went to school and i did okay
and look at this nice house
all events paid for everything's paid
for nice big tv
i'm thinking
you have done okay she's got a point how
how am i telling the school
that if you don't go to school and get
an education you're gonna be there where
her mom's going
i think all right so part of it's
cultural as well
yeah so if we're living in those
cultures where
you know we don't value education or we
don't value aspiration
or we're not saying to our kids you can
be a doctor you know i want you to be a
doctor
always saying i want you to you know
work here or do this or do that
if we're just saying to young people i
don't care what you do
um makes no difference to me mate so how
do you help kids
it's really about giving them a dream
it's about building their aspiration
it's about making them believe in
themselves
the thing i've heard the most and the
thing that upsets me the most
is when young people when i say to young
people
what do you want to be you know when you
what's your dream and they go
nothing i got a dream eve
i prefer when they say i want to be a
football player and you know we know
they're not
but at least i've got a dream but when
you've got young people saying
nothing i got it for you and you dig
down you speak so you get to know them
over weeks you find out
and you realize they meant it
what happened to them was they had a
dream
they tried stuff and they either got no
support
usually from home or parents or school
or they failed or stumbled
and nobody helped him up and no one gave
him the encouragement to start again
and eventually they learnt themselves
that if i don't try
i don't fail but doesn't this go back to
fatherlessness
that they've got nobody there to go yeah
come on pick yourself up look we all
fail
and that's what fathers do so when you
come on you know you're running the
house crying you've cut your knee
your dad does stop being a big baby
you're fine
get back out there well your mum goes ah
oh go get the first aid there that goes
oh
your leg's not gonna get out that
builds resilience then you go all right
and
dad's come across as cruel sometimes but
they're not cruel
that's what dads do that's why we need a
mum and a dad
less extraordinary circumstances yeah
and you know
when you come on when you're being
bullied your dad doesn't go
we're gonna have to speak the school and
we know we're gonna have to get taxed to
pick you up and we're gonna have to do
this and do that
yeah that goes all right well tomorrow
when the first one comes up to you
you smack him as hard as you can in the
face and the others will either run away
or you're gonna get battered but i'll
tell you what they won't they won't mess
with you the day after
because they'll all know someone's
getting a fist in the nose
or your dad will walk with you to school
and your dad will threaten them
and they all go don't mess with him his
dad's mental
we've all got different roles and that's
what we're missing out
with fathers we're missing these young
people seeing their dad go out to work
every day
in the wind the snow the hovercam
getting up at six seven in the morning
not coming back till six seven at night
knackered
sitting down what's daddy
i can't play football with this one i'm
absolutely shattered
kind of been working oh but that well do
you know where the lights are on
can i pay the rent and i pay the bills
do you know why you're just eating
because i give you more money and she
goes out and buys food for you
where does that money come from it's me
working six seven eight nine ten hours a
day
and young people go right someone's got
to work
for me to have stuff and these are all
the lessons
we used to teach our children
and there weren't lessons as in we we
knew we were teaching them
they were just in heaven but all that's
gone
and especially young boys are just
drifting
and they're looking for that father
figure
that someone to look up to and someone
to respect
and they're finding it in negative
malevolent models outside the house
do you know i listen to you and you're
so right
and i listen to you with the twitter
brain on
and i'm going we're going to get
cancelled so [ __ ] hard for this
because these things have become
unsavable okay
i was i was a teacher in in east london
a very deprived part of east london in
newham
and i looked at the boys who were
struggling in my class
and i'd be like no dad no dad no dad no
dad
the vast majority of them and it's not
their fault those kids
it's because as you said they've been
failed by their fathers
because and people don't want to say
this but if you have a kid
that is your responsibility your
responsibility
okay we can't say it enough it's your
responsibility
and men who abandoned their children
should be publicly shamed
you should be ashamed of sitting in the
pub and saying
oh yeah i've got two kids oh oh yeah i i
i'm not swimming years
that should be like saying well yeah i
did four years in jail for for
pedophilia
it should be almost the same as that
because
you're damaging your own children you
might not see it
and it holds a long time and it's
emotional but you're damaging
your own flesh and blood and if you
don't want to have your own flesh and
blood
they're called condoms so we've got a
choice
and that's not to say that every young
person who doesn't have a father in his
home
is destined to be a criminal that's not
the case because i don't have a father
so it's not to say you know that happens
but we look at the overall stats and
who's failing
in the years i've spent working with
young people
it's like oh yeah again again
again and we see it and there's a
wonderful book by um
call it was called the boy crisis by
i think the warren favel have you read
it yes
you need to if you if you're not ready
you need to read it's a wonderful book
and it talks about all of this before
we go i just one question i want to ask
nick what advice would you give to
someone
who's going through an experience
similar to yours what should they do
what should they not do
first thing is join the free speech
union
because they're great and they can help
you um
don't ever apologize for something
you're not sorry for
because i wouldn't do it so if you've
done something and you know it's wrong
then you need to apologize it's called
being a decent human being but if you've
done nothing wrong don't apologize
and then depending on your situation you
need to work about you need to work out
how you can fight back um and
try to use some of the tactics that
they've used against you
for you such as social media such as
online petitions
seek out people like me and other people
um
who have got the presence online and
let's get a petition
started for you it might not work but
make you feel better when 18 000 people
have signed it
and don't do what i did the first week
which was to accept defeat
um if the biggest mistake they made with
me
was they gave me nothing else to lose
and when you when you put someone in the
corner who's got nothing else to lose
you either die or you fight your way out
that corner
and if they've done the same to you then
that's your choice i have a die in that
corner
i'll fight your way out because you've
got nothing else to lose
one of our favorite quotes on this show
is the fight club i don't know if you've
seen that movie which is
it's only once you've lost everything
that you're free to do anything
and thank you for coming on the show
nick thank you for taking the stand
i'm glad you landed on your feet and it
sounds to me like there's some really
great things ahead in the future for you
and as a result for young people in this
country because i really think you can
make
a huge contribution to improving their
lives and i hope people who watch this
and people who listen to this who have
the ability to change things
take what you've said on board with that
in mind as always we've got one more
question for you
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society
but we really should be we're talking
about a little bit but not anything like
we should
and it's the knifecraft epidemic that
we've got
how have we got hundreds of young people
stabbing each other to death every year
and it seems as if
we are lost
for an answer it it baffles me
part of it is we don't understand people
who tackle it obviously understand it
but the vast majority of people don't
understand it
you know people think it's really drug
truth wars
and it tends not to be about drug terror
for it tends to be like respect
it tends to be about have you seen what
he put on twitter about you about your
mum
are you going to have that i wouldn't
have it if he
said that to me about my mum i'd knife
him and all of a sudden that young
person then
feels like there's nothing else i can do
now all my friends are saying i won't
have that
and then they're backed into a corner
and then we have violence
and we're not we're not looking at it
seriously enough
and we're not tackling it enough because
of the racial
element we have and everyone again is
paranoid
about looking at it because it's
predominantly young black men stabbing
other young black men
and i had a thought the other day which
i've not really locked into
and it just popped in the head 150 years
ago in the uk
we had a problem of dueling and that was
all with respect
so we'd have you know sir you said what
about my
my wife i will see you tomorrow at dawn
and we had people stabbing and shooting
each other to death over respect
we need to look at why that happened
and how we tackled it in other countries
how have we tackled young men
taking offense which is easily done in
every culture throughout history
and resorting to violence which what
young men do
so this is a new problem yeah but we
don't i can't see anywhere where we're
looking at it
and coming up with solutions we just
seem to be
what obviously it is is an outcry
how can this happen and i think it's a
shame
well nick thank you so much for coming
on the show if people want to find you
on twitter
twitter facebook all those places nick
buckley
mbe perfect stuff uh thank you so much
for watching the show guys we hope you
enjoy it
please uh follow us on twitter and all
the usual socials and if you want to see
a show of ours
wednesday and sunday our episodes
tuesday thursday
friday and saturday are our live streams
and they always go out 7pm
uk time we'll see you soon
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word